>>Asia: This chair
is for the presenter.
This is for the person
who created the trailer.
You're going to say how you
decided to do your trailer.
Then we'll do warm and cool feedback.
>>Narrator: In this
digital storytelling class
at Carter G. Woodson Middle School
on the south side of Chicago,
students are learning to
express themselves using new
media technologies.
>>Student: I liked how you
incorporated everything together
and made it dramatic.
>>Narrator: And learning how
to critique what they see.
>>Student: Because it seemed
like the sound effects took over
and you really couldn't
hear yourself.
>>Narrator: Carter G. Woodson
is one of four schools that make
up the Digital Youth Network or DYN,
a sixth through twelfth grade program
that was created in
2003 by the University
of Chicago's Urban
Education Institute.
>>Nichole: The Digital Youth Network
takes up the challenge preparing kids
for the year 2020 and beyond.
And we do that in trying to create
partnerships between all the spaces
where kids spend their time
during the school day, in school,
after school, and after-school
programming, at home through the use
of online tools and social networks,
and in the communities
that surround them.
>>Akili: If you could if you
know your account, log in.
>>Nichole: So we've tried to allow
kids to sort of learn on demand.
>>Jared: Through Digital
Youth Network and presence
of DYN classes inside the school
day our students are gaining access
to software and skills that really
push the envelope on what we think
or what teachers think
they're capable of doing.
>>Student: What did you
guys do with those pictures?
>>Student: They're all right there.
>>Narrator: During the school day
DYN staff teach mandatory media
arts classes.
There students acquire
basic tech literacy skills
that allow classroom teachers
to integrate digital tools
into their curriculum.
>>Akili: So again, you can
upload the music y'all are doing,
and you can also make blog posts and
start discussion forums etcetera.
>>Narrator: After school,
students can pursue their passions
in a variety of DYN classes that
meet for two hours once a week.
They include digital
video production.
>>Teacher: Yeah, make sure you're
moving your play head
and then play from the beginning.
>>Narrator: Digital audio
production, robotics,
graphic design, and game design.
>>Student: I made it based on
[inaudible] game so I tried
to make it like with
some type of fortress-
>>Jalen: DYN is just like one of the
awesomest, sickest programs ever.
It's like technically it's just
like all these awesome sick programs
like gaming all the way to poetry.
And after that we have
something called Freedom Friday
and there sometimes we talk about
topics that need to be talked
about around the world
like global warming.
>>Teacher: We have many
perspectives, not just one.
And you could add to
that perspective.
>>Narrator: There's also a Digital
Queendom offering just for girls.
>>Teacher: Alright,
ladies, thank you.
>>Akili: Digital Queendom
is an initiative
to really support gender equity.
Girls often thought that they
couldn't necessarily do the work
to the same level that
the boys would,
so we brought the Digital Queendom
pod in giving the girls kind
of a safe space and in
a more engaging kind
of context that's focused
on their own issues.
>>Teacher: Think about the kind
of advertising too that
you've seen before.
What is it they try to
tell you to get you to-
>>Asia: We discuss and analyze
and critically break down images
of females in the media, anything
that has the female presence in it,
we break it down to see what is
empowerment, what isn't empowerment,
and how they can create media
that better reflects themselves.
>>Narrator: The DYN
network is accessible 24/7
through its closed social
network site called Remix World.
Students post their work, take
part in critiques and discussions
and receive online mentoring
which expands learning beyond
the school and program day.
>>Teacher: Did you put sound to this?
>>Student: Yeah, yes and
no, I don't like it anymore.
>>Akili: If you want them to really
be a sophisticated game developer
or a graphic designer
or a videographer.
It's hard to do that with once a
week so we use the online space
as an extension and an opportunity
for the kids really on their own time
to really delve a little
bit deeper into the work.
>>Student: We just talked about
the presidential election.
>>Narrator: Once in high
school, DYN students begin
to focus their development
on an individual medium.
>>Terrence: And action.
>>Narrator: Oftentimes
youth who excelled
in the middle school program are
given internship opportunities
to serve as mentors for
middle school students.
>>Terrence: Okay, I'm not sure
if we're going to get that shot.
>>Terrence: Being a mentor you
know really teaches me skills
about working in a
productive environment.
You know, it teaches me
how to be professional,
how to take those skills that I have
already and enhance them and how
to teach another generation
how to use those
and so hopefully there can be kids
that I'm teaching who could wind
up being bigger and more famous
than I hope to be, you know?
>>Right now I'm editing the clip
shorter so that it kind of looks more
like a movie and not like just
like pictures just
floating out of the air.
So I'm going to see how
that works out first.
>>Jared: We know that the world is
shifting and that there are a number
of new ways of thinking, new
ways of learning and working
and socializing that won't go away.
It's not a fad.
It's not a trend.
And the way people connect,
the way people work,
the way people learn
is very different
so we think our kids need
the ability to use technology
in their personal development
and in their learning.
>>Hi, this is:
>>The Random Show!
>>And you are watching it on DYN TV.
>>For more information on what works
in public education
go to edutopia.org